what is up everybody it's Anna Mac and
welcome to another episode of the week's
best anime videos which is a weekly
anime newscast on our channel the links
are in the description recommendations
go in the comment now actually miss this
news from last week but soul maka from
our discourse server was kind enough to
link me to a gaijin Goomba video which
talks about this crazy anime export
banned in Japan apparently a Japanese
publishing company named a vex group
recently announced that they would be
restricting the exports of CDs DVDs and
blu-rays for major anime titles
including fairy tale one piece
assassination classroom and even Yuri on
ice these kinds of things could be
happening because of logistical issues
legal issues because laws are different
in every country or financial issues
needless to say a lot of fans outside of
Japan are very worried that they're not
going to be able to get the cds dvds and
blu-rays for their favorite anime
anymore I definitely recommend checking
out gaijin goombas full video because he
explains everything in great detail and
speedo urea nice i mentioned in the last
episode that joey the anime man finally
uploaded his double seasonal anime round
of last week and since then there has
been some controversy about Joey's
critical tone towards Yuri oh nice now I
don't want to rehash this whole thing
but apparently some urea nights fan not
all but some tried to claim that joy
should not be criticizing urien eyes
because of the subject matter that urea
nice deals with and because joy cannot
personally relate to that specific
subject matter but long story short Joey
did nothing wrong just because a certain
anime deals with social issues that are
close to your heart or have features
characters that are dear to you that
does not make it immune from criticism
let me be clear no one should be
demanding special treatment from critics
for any specific anime no matter what
the subject matter because after all
special treatment is the opposite of
equality in other news that animates
knob actually made a video last week in
which he kind of called me out and told
me to read his book so what I decided to
do is to accept his offer I am going to
read this book and I'm going to
critically analyze it live on our
channel along with some friends cyanide
Blizzard Briggs from all day anime and
maybe one or two special guests youtuber
as you may know here on this channel we
hold a weekly live stream or podcast
called ran cafe every thursday at five
p.m. eastern standard time and in a few
weeks time we're going to hold a special
episode of ram cafe where we're going to
be analyzing snobs book live and
discussing it with you guys hearing your
feedback and all that kind of stuff I'm
actually really looking forward to this
I want to see the snob can put his
writing where his mouth is so stay tuned
here to this channel for more specific
information about when the live stream
is actually going to take place I
actually haven't featured a good video
on this newscast in a few weeks which is
unusual but this week he uploaded a
video called six more brilliant fights
in anime I really enjoyed his previous
best fights in anime video and I checked
this one out and it was really good as
well so I definitely recommend checking
it out link is in the description and
speaking of action in anime this week
watchmojo uploaded a top 10 anime for
action fans video now this list wasn't
perfect but it was actually quite good
it featured anime like cowboy bebop
darker than black and black lagoon and
it was designed to get fans of action
who are not yet anime fans into anime
which is something i really respect my
one problem with this video is that the
guy narrating it has some of the worst
pronunciation of japanese names that
I've ever heard I honestly thought he
was trolling us for a while it was that
bad so even if you're not a fan of
action anime check out this video just
to hear how he pronounces Satsuki
kiryuin please please just listen to how
he pronounces Satsuki kiryuin and they
were all led by one of animes most
badass ladies that to Kiki Ryu is that
to Kiki Ryu a change and for my favorite
AMV this week I actually picked one that
combines two anime reesy row and tokyo
ghoul in a very interesting and artistic
way this amv was made by a small
youtuber called zim zim and it was
actually recommended to me by briggs
from all day anime definitely check out
this MV and shows them's in some love
you did a great job bro and that's it
for this week guys if you like these
videos be sure to LIKE and subscribe and
until next time see up space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
I